you want to talk a little bit about the
uh the coming down the pike at us likely
eua to
uh to allow the vaccines for 5 to 11
year olds yeah i just wanted to point
out something that's increasingly um
sitting very badly with me
there has been obviously a tremendous
amount of ink spilled and uh video
produced of people disagreeing over what
the correct response is to
the evidence we have regarding the
vaccines available to us the disease
what their interaction is right should
we be vaccinating the very vulnerable
right should it be a ring pattern should
we really be trying to vaccinate
everybody in the middle of a pandemic
there are real arguments to be had about
what the wise thing is and there is no
room for a real argument
have you seen ring pattern proposed yeah
fascinating uh yeah i mean the fact is
there's lots there's lots of room to
have an honest discussion about what's
the best way to deal with the tools
we've got and the diseases we face
right yeah there's lots of things we can
do and we're not having any of these
discussions in an honorable fashion and
it's maddening but here's what i see
many people including
friends of ours very smart people
who some of whom
do have the scientific chops to evaluate
this stuff
and some of whom don't
have
in my opinion and i assume our opinion
gotten this dead wrong and they have
understood um the fictions that we are
being sold as noble lies that we should
probably embrace
what i don't understand
is why at the point that we are being
told that five to 11 year olds
should be vaccinated that a it's
acceptable to vaccinate them and b that
maybe they should be
mandated why is this not waking people
up who accepted the past excuse that
these were noble lies designed to
control a pandemic and that we didn't
want to burden people with the nuances
of
the actual risk benefit analysis
there's no defense as far as i can see
for vaccinating people so young if
they're healthy
if they are healthy they will endure
covid very very well and they will
acquire
a durable kind of immunity from an
encounter with it and so the idea of
putting them at risk of original
antigenic
sin in this case of signing them up if
what you're going to have is
immunity from the
vaccines that then wanes that then
requires boosters
somebody 5 to 11 is going to need a
whole lot longer series of boosters if
we don't have an alternative coming down
the pike and frankly
you may should a good vaccine show up
you may limit their ability to take
advantage of it because you will have
already cannalized their immune system
in a direction there is no defense
what's more
every booster carries the risk of
adverse events and we can argue about
how many adverse events there are but
when the disease has essentially
no
risk for young
children the idea of exposing them to
any significant risk of myocarditis or
any other serious adverse event is very
very hard to justify
so one thing that we were talking about
off air was
that as you all can imagine
brett and i have had a lot of
conversations about this
some of them on air but most by far the
majority of them off air
and
we talk weekly about you know
what
what the conditions might be
that would prompt us to decide that it
was necessary to get vaccinated with the
current vaccines
and
what we have both agreed to and
didn't take even
saying it aloud although we have
was that uh
the evidence is so overwhelming
across so many domains
that what we cannot imagine
allowing
is letting those near our children
that is
given the evidence for
the danger of the pathogen to young
people and the danger of the vaccines to
young people young men in particular of
which we have two
that is a very normal parental response
yeah
you know
you may be able
to get that near me but
do not get it near my children
where is that response i think this is
the question that you are asking why are
we why do we not seem to be seeing that
response
in the public conversation as the
age limit for these is dropping lower
and lower yeah it's very strange and i
would just point out that there are
other little nuances in here um there's
a question about you know i mean
the idea of being forced to the vaccine
is obviously you know one's freedoms are
potentially on the line here so it's not
unreasonable to judge even an
unacceptable level of risk against other
costs
probably in our case uh if we were going
to be forced it would make sense to to
have one of us
uh be vaccinated in the other one just
because we don't know what the long-term
implications of this are nobody does and
just in terms of protecting our family
from various possible outcomes there's a
question about what you do and i don't i
don't know what the answer is but
um
but it is so odd to see people who
clearly have the capacity and the
information to understand that
something is wrong to the extent that we
are rushing to the idea that if vaccines
are inherently good and this is just a
vaccine and it makes sense for everybody
to get it that that necessarily applies
to people
this
young and
i hesitate to say this because i
understand it can be inflammatory but in
some sense
this looks like
um i think it would be generous to call
it a religious
response
um is this a
kind of built-in response in which
people
um
are effectively making a sacrifice of
their own children
um
to
some sort of uh belief system and i i
feel the same way as i watch children
leaving school 19 and 20 of them as i've
been counting
masked even though it's broad daylight
with plenty of uv light they're walking
largely
alone
they're effectively at no risk of covet
and this disease isn't particularly
dangerous to them at all and yet they
appear not to be questioning it's as if
they are born into a family that has
embraced a religious or in this case
it's not religious because it hasn't
stood the test of time it's a cult
structure yeah well it it you know the
rules as they make less and less sense
definitely enhance compliance and that's
part of that's part of the point
[Music]
you